si su ritmo cardíaco es anormal es
posible que su médico realice una
electro cardioversión en la que se
utiliza una descarga eléctrica para
normalizar sus latidos del corazón
normalmente late a un ritmo regular de
60 a 100 latidos por minuto este ritmo
estable y coordinado permite que el
corazón bombea sangre de manera eficaz
de señales eléctricas que viajan a
través del corazón controlan el ritmo
cardíaco estas señales eléctricas
comienzan en un grupo de células
denominado nódulos y un auricular o
marcapasos el nódulo sin auricular o
nódulo s/a se encuentra en la pared de
la cámara superior derecha del corazón
denominada atrio derecho cuando las
señales eléctricas llegan al músculo del
corazón hacen que este se contraiga y
bombea sangre al ritmo cardíaco anormal
se le denomina arritmia durante la
fibrilación atrial el atrio se agita
debido a las señales eléctricas caóticas
en el corazón lo que da como resultado
latidos irregulares o anormalmente
rápidos debido a los latidos anormales
es posible que la sangre se acumule en
él
lo que puede ocasionar que se forme un
coágulo de sangre
si el coágulo de sangre ingresa a la
circulación general
podría causar un accidente
cerebrovascular
antes del procedimiento se le conectará
a una vía intravenosa
usted será sedado de modo que dormirá
durante el procedimiento los electrodos
de encaje se colocarán en su pecho para
controlar la actividad eléctrica de su
corazón
una vez sedado se colocarán almohadillas
o paletas de cardioversión especiales
sobre la piel de su pecho o en su pecho
y espalda
estas almohadillas o paletas aplicarán
un disparo eléctrico a través de su
pecho hasta su corazón es posible que se
repita el disparo varias veces hasta que
el corazón recupere su ritmo normal
después de la cardioversión eléctrica se
le controlará de cerca en una sala de
recuperación o en la unidad de cuidados
coronarios del hospital una vez que
desaparezcan los efectos del sedante y
usted se encuentre en una condición
estable podrá volver a casa